gibt es viel mehr planeten in unserem
sonnensystem als bisher gedacht us
astronomen wollen die rück klassen
beziehung des verkleinerten blutdruck in
einen planeten
doch das hätte weitreichende folgen da
fällt nämlich auf dass wir unzählige
himmelskörper im sonnensystem hätten die
ähnliche kriterien erfüllen würden so
viele riesige himmelskörper im
sonnensystem wieder plötzlich als
planeten gelten würden
das muss geklärt werden in klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
110 planeten wie bitte so viel können
die fahrtechnisch im goms sehen sein
ging es nach einem us-forscher die milo
weshalb warum
im jahr 2006 gab es eine revolution
hunderte vorschläge auf die barrikaden
und protestiert es gab zwar keine
straßenschlachten oder demos aber für
die forscher war es fast so revolutionär
wie schrieben einen brief eine petition
gegen die entscheidung der international
renommierte junien view den pluto dem
planeten status abzuerkennen und es kam
zu unerhörtem sie drohten sogar damit
diese entscheidung einfach zu ignorieren
zwar gibt es heute immer noch kritiker
aber die proteste verliefen im sande zu
kuchenpause spielt nicht gewesen gute
wohnung zum vermieten degradiert und die
folgen waren schlimm
im januar war gerade die sonne new
orleans gestartet um den letzten
planeten unseres sonnensystems zu
erkunden und jetzt war er weg sie flog
zudem viel weniger bedeutenden
zwergplaneten pluto
das ist natürlich ziemlich infos beim
team von united aber die wissenschaftler
der mission ruhen nicht und wollen ihre
reputation unbedingt wieder herstellen
für sie war es eine schmach im juni 2015
kein planeten sondern nur einen zweck
planeten erforscht haben
es war einfach spektakuläre fotos die da
zur erde gefunkt wurden aber halt nur
von einem zwergplanet aber das soll sich
jetzt ändern forscher um carrie gremien
von der johns hopkins university wollen
den pluto wieder zum planeten machen
dafür schlagen wie vor die kriterien vom
planeten zu ändern bitter ging es danach
ob das gestirn in einer kreisrunden bahn
um die sonne sieht ob das gestirn selbst
kugelförmig ist und ob die flugbahn von
anderen objekten freigeräumt und genau
letzteres gilt nicht für den pluto
filter plätzchen kriterium aber nicht
mehr gibt es unzählige objekte die mit
porto auch zu planeten würden da sind
zum beispiel die aktuellen werk
langenfeld wester juno pallas im
abbiegen würde zwischen mars und jupiter
oder im kultursaal opposition war nach
der meck meck und iris und zahlreiche
weitere objekte wurden dazu kommen es
werden insgesamt 110 planeten
ich finde die initiative deshalb super
interessantes längst die perspektive
darauf wie für fast unzählige größere
objekte um die sonne kreisen
dabei wurden aktuell noch nicht mal mit
gefällt und einige der zwergplaneten zum
beispiel sind fast so groß wie bluetooth
wer einen durchmesser von 2320
kilometern hat super spannend finde ich
auch dass zum beispiel die jupitermonde
allesamt größer als pluto sind kein
wunder dass auch sie so intensiv
erforscht werden allerdings gibt es mit
der planeten definition des pluto ein
wirkliches problem und das könnte
theoretisch sogar zu zehntausenden neuen
planeten führen wenn wir den körper
gürtel um unser sonnensystem besser
erforschen sondern ist es wahrscheinlich
zehntausende objekte gewinnen die die
vorgeschlagenen definition erfüllen
bisher sind dort nur einige hundert
transnet typische objekte also objekte
die weiter als neptun von der sonne
entfernt in bekannt aber es könnte neben
zehntausende werden die einen
durchmesser von mehr als 100 kilometern
dann haben und das würde dann
tatsächlich etwas unübersichtlich werden
was du alles da draußen noch unerforscht
ist mehr erfahrt ihr täglich hier bei
pixum mir einfach hier mit einem klick
ein abo auf auge drücken und nicht
vergessen wir danach ein flug warten auf
die glocke zu geben und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran